This is Anna Clark here for the Brooklyn public library and here with Marty
Needleman executive director and chief counsel at Brooklyn Legal Services Corporation.
And a long time Williams Hello thank you for a green
tough day for the project for our street
stories about.
Here and working and.
Actually I'm a newcomer I came in one thousand nine hundred eighty nine.
Right from law school I was
a I was a VISTA volunteer lawyer and
I growing up in East New York. My first fifty years and same block
the snow white flight we were forced to have the T.V.'s Canarsie
then I lived in Brooklyn my whole
life. I thought pointed with the boys University Law School at the Brooklyn
College and love for the sixty's and I thought of going to Boston.
I want to do public interest after the jobs available got a bit to join Vista volunteers and service to
America as a lawyer and got
to go I thought I was a go to Texas or Oklahoma and then come back to Boston which I
love and the special program they had which is two years rather than one
year and we interviewed the people who have been the program the five boys we've
been the program before that and one guy when he wrote them I
went in to be my mentor and a
great description of what he's doing that time so I joined I said
come to Waynesburg for two years I've been here ever since.
And they talked about growing up in Brooklyn.
Well it was in my my block Alabama Avenue in East New York
was like a little village. It was at that time was all working class and poor Jewish people.
The Jews originally came to lower east
side and then the next generation the business people moved in the middle class
more middle class mainstream Jews. Not good for the Jews.
To Williamsburg Red Cross the bridge the poor
Jews the working class and and and blank and Jews moved to New York in Brownsville.
My family. And we live in same UK for eighteen
years and it was like a village.
Pete my smiter help my elementary school is a block from my house and then but it
was people were
super friendly brain we should have been different ages and so we knew what they
were blocking people who you know everybody. And it was a very it was a like a village very so
that when white flight happened when put we can start moving
in and all the whites we were the last white family left my family on our block.
It was very touching to me because I feel like I lost my home my my my my town.
And so actually I realize that there are a lot of a lot that had an impact on my future life
in terms of defending people's right to stay and trying to preserve communities which is what we're
here and the fact is though if I moved away as broken in ways. Ever since I live in the same
block in Leesburg for the last forty five since one thousand and
seventy two so
it's thirty three to forty three and forty three
years black and. It weaves back the whole time so it so
a lot of the fighting a lot of my life and my work by those experiences as
a young person and flood thinking is OK.
Was there anything.
That's just I was very supportive I guess it was a village
of most people in those days the world has changed a lot since then but most days
most of the people have been come from Europe prior generations. My parents were both born
United States but my grandparents were from here.
And so it was there's no conservative or form to this is all.
See that observant doctor the like us.
We kept kosher the house that we change we also we kept
certain laws young Kipper Russia China.
Passover. But nothing else not not the Sabbath because that's why the work of US
postal workers that work in the news a clerk in even the main post office. And so he
had to work and if that was so he but we let them service and we would not that we
didn't follow the Jewish holidays like she will or the certain other hell they said was at
the right. And many people I think most of the people like that.
And we went to a school that have. With the public schools with the beautiful gift.
It was a very warm and support like I said like a village
people were very supportive and United a lot of weight on neighbors and very neighborly.
Here.
Well when I started out as I said I was a Vista and I was the reason I was pulling Saudi royal
family at the time. My present my predecessor My
mentor was working with parents so Cajun Thank you New
groups in the struggle for communicants role schools the ocean Brownfield
days
and length you know ahead of that struggle over community controls much part as
part of much larger movement
afoot civil rights and. And a communicant show
and very successful and was involved in organizing it with
what we did legal work that will support a lot of struggles.
And so
then I did I did that for about three years exclusively education related work
with those groups and then the world changed the
City College dated those things with elections for Community School Boys things like
that so kind of change and kind
of petered out in a successful way.
So then you know and the early seventies.
It's switched and I think it was I work with community groups as the next phase of what they
were involved with was a struggle to get local workers into the
construction trades was a myth about the construction going
on for example in one thousand nine hundred eighty six were all hostile five hundred
units opened up
the horizon. What it was called in those days Bell
Telephone and a new main major building opened then test it
was constructed and opened up one new house me built in the in
the early seventy's and it will be really the
Democratic administrations that but I always wondered how they felt it was. There were
three developments.
Well public health three new developments. Fifteen hundred apartments constructed
in that period and the other way is bring water from itself lean very much to the lot of
jobs construction jobs in those days. Construction jobs were united in their own
way and an Irish worker and was hit was father to son him down.
So in order to get the jobs we had. Demonstrate on the site stop construction very often
and organize and mobilize.
To get people on the construction site locally here and then they were
merged into the
union and a very successful campaign it was worth it was very successful. There
were demonstrations of people got arrested and like that.
And actually that was in conjunction with fight back which And then some things and had a
second group and
didn't
take the low. Good good I'm actually in the middle of an interview
here but what's
happening. Here I think I probably got it
but what is the
say OK great. So I
can make it. A couple of people be there as well so.
It's me put there for thirty for of any help.
If you get there a little early every great
to be there for OK Great great.
Thanks. So.
Sorry.
Yes So this is I was at then.
Construction was none the wiser over that at that stage and then in one thousand nine hundred
seventy three.
I get
called if you know how I got a call back a call to attend association
group under visionary new who isn't right off the bat for
them and they were complaining people in the book is sick and I will try
to get them out of the buildings at that time his security had begun to
develop
really like in suffering's book which is actually very very
good between here. There is just one block past Broadway to the to
the Navy Yard to the river and they were growing and they
were pushing out to see what had become like you
know families there. And so this is what it was like he went
fifteen Division you have your so I go to the meeting and I tell him I bring back my
background which is the organizing and legal stuff together we talk about it so how we're
going to fight but then I got pneumonia and I was out of the office read a
week and I came to the building with
him that in that week it all happened so I said to myself on that
like that happen in an economic it's
reverberated with my own history of epic displacement and I get over being displaced myself for
other
reasons and then the next two buildings similar things were
happening next to buildings. One is one upright equestrian away division and then went off for the mission
and we. That was the beginning of
my business work and about six months after I began working with the first
one way to Vision interview.
BARBOUR slip. Joint Committee organization called closer race the
south itself and United Front Office join to and participate with
me and with the organizer. It's actually me we were together in that building of the first building.
We worked on the first one we're on together with and she still has
a meeting with the credits in that building every month since one thousand nine hundred eighty four.
And what happened was it was the beginning of a lot of the stuff that
we we want to battle against a
specific history related landlord who actually was in this
building before we own this building right here. We had offices you came in one
hundred sixty acres and do a lot of private offices here and yet again it's
real estate office here and we organize me to organize attendance
and fighting for court cases. So I'll use
materials about what our strategy is generally up its next nomic bores hold back the rent
and bring a firm of case
than fight the nonpayment cases take advantage of the nonfunctional you the courts against limits
as opposed to what's going on now in the wise which is level taken care of forcing tennis to pay because.
And so and it was a
memorable moment
because it. I was on the third floor or us and second for the time here.
Third floor and he was on the fourth floor anybody be afeared I know very
well. Well from those who passed away and that's the five of
the Holocaust itself.
And he he said this is one thousand nine hundred seventy
four a little off you know if you four thousand dollars drop the case.
That four thousand dollars and eight hundred seventy four. So I said I can't take myself
out a lot for there's been no nothing for
you. His secretary saying to take it and I saw him
to say
so the next day or a day later a guy walks into the building throws him off
of cocktail. And hit the building right now and we get to
that perhaps again an old one who remains in the building. So
I called the F.B.I. told what happened if you guys came down
here. And he said What should I ask him
for nothing but one person stay in the
building and he brought to court cases we've got and we have
a court order.
We get the first appointed seven a number of that there's a provision of the law that's it that letter statute that
allows
for one third of the tenants in the building to see your point of an administrator. But
a polygamist
traitor to take people to run a
building and hardly look from from entering the building your position is only if
you present. I think what you're looking to do
over here
was really big thing and that's how we got
to seventy
point and that was a decade with tending for
the fire in the
facility verifying
and we got some funding and the
stories communication lengths and money that a bill that a building survival fund and they let some
money to serve a minister said. So the other part of the war was the
statue had
been stuck in the fifty's was going Jesse gray to try to organize Harlem the hall and
ranch strike if that was resolved. They passed this that was they passed a
law allowing for tennis to bring these cases to prevent them from the ranch strikes.
But only one guy brawny
him and Laurie thought that these cases and it was really that love because you can find the ministries willing to do
it with no money involved and three percent of the ransom resolute.
However what we did is we if the court to appoint. They had a community organization that looks or is
who is you know to be a lawyer or real
estate broker or her or a notary or a.
It would be a lot of licensed broker or attorney or C.P.A..
So none of them want to depict but the head
of the Commune organization most serious was a lawyer.
And so we had come to a point in the court declined to do so but it's at the pump we're going to want
to have our guy appointed. So we had to step two was we had
a seventy mistruth a point to that our
guy didn't pay rent and we did a racetrack against him and he can bring a court case
against attendance for it but he had no money rapping about his pocket
because they wanted the money in the pennant in the seven A So he back
that he the you withdrew.
And we got our guy and that got to separated. Actually the reaping fifty of the building
and restoring it in the tenants move back in.
Many of them had gotten them into new public housing it was being built at the same
time. So that children came in for many of them to this
day are people who were involved in the struggles early on and it became with them and
then what happened was if you get a trend seventy seven administrate
or less transfer the rent for The only be used for beer and make the
building not for taxes not for old
debts that for mortgages enough a problem. So the landlord wants the retain
the building that a pay the fact that their own pockets are paid those old bills and those days no matter how
wealthy these limits
were and it's still somewhat true today that they had to pay
money have their own pockets and no say that there was so many building that has let it go let it go.
The city took its attacks took it from textbook pushing the city to want to the city they created
a program called attended
to release program prototype for the seven eighth's Relief Program where they leased building to
disseminate ministry. The city owns a bit more and they contain to seven
administrations in the city
develop a program that can bring these two loans and costs. Under a state statute cool
the private housing finance laws housing development funds
corporations Costco to expose the person to low income.
And the twenty fifth and then that they sold the apartments for Twitter still as the shares of the
apartments in this coffee for twenty or fifty dollars an apartment purchase price and
they were able to maintain very low rent to this day the rents are extra are maintained blowing
and continued because it shows you how much money is involved in the profit in these
buildings without having to make a profit. You can keep rents low and maintain the building in reasonable condition.
And to this day they have now they are now and then the same thing happened next door.
There was not been a pressure to bring their limit then up front then later than that from the building them but she did everything possible
and we won that case all the same thing seven A.M. She was
up. And she was a wild person. My wife and my
family went on Yom Kippur. You go to your dream the Jewish that was
that period time you look to the water you can throw your sins
symbolically and the waters near where the concentration is security officials see
sorest going that
day me and my wife my two young
kids and she such screaming at
us and a crowd formed and were almost
violent and to call the police and simply because of it we had
a weapon that my friend surrounded us and watches that but that
was kind of people go but we took that bill that was one of what the mission
which Barbara still works with to this day. Likewise and that was that
began the trend and we've we've been led to believe that the years in those days was
slumlords or that his him trying to get to let you know example for other Hasidim.
And
so. As I said people the slumlords were there
was bought by a building scandal it was out in the on the south side
where it was not the city. It was something
else the the mainstream Jewish community moved
out and replace but mostly Latinos coming
in but and this is a trend that was throughout the larger Very simply most
linear thing probably a lot of you know logic places that the little it
will brokers with to its lowest level it
would buy the building scared the landlords out here we're going to
coming in this were worth nothing by the building
she sell it to the next level or the collector and for him and recover
their their investment in two years. And sell to sell to sell the building and make a
fifty percent profit on top of that.
And recover their investment they get fifty separate until the next level and content that they will paint the hallways and say we're
going to be OK for me in the world here. The same exact thing and then finally they bring the building that was a very
common Bronx and burnings a
pattern here in Williamsburg resisted that and Billy's way of doing. So
that during the pretenders goes on seventy's and eighty's early
ninety's with both stories and of community organizations in other parts of win
for Green Point.
There were over one hundred twenty buildings that were taken and made the co-ops as a result of the struggles.
Which compete in the course compete. In addition to that. So that's
that's that was a there was a deep sense of like of the work of the whole with those trucks
and sink next neighbor
the same looks Alliance now. Something different in East
Williamsburg and
South Korean point in North Korea point is not present building
Corp in the north side those people's firehouse in the group called an egg was originally neighbors
against garbage no neighbors aligned with the group.
But that coalition and that we've expanded to Bushwick over the years.
Bush recounting the pendants project.
So that that was the work that was the bulk of the work and then. Working with the parents O.C.A.
sions and the cost to manage the buildings with the organizers there are
a lot of logistical legal issues and some of us just McCandless in terms of managing the
building and our goal has always been with his associations with these co-ops.
Transparency and collective decision making reports with
everything all the business is done it means monthly
meetings rents a collective range strike or co-op at the meetings with you to
get out at the ME support be given at the meetings checks aside that the meetings only approved by the group
and that all the tenants or director over the head but that's a great majority.
So that's that's that's
a very famous sometimes of you know nothing prepping those We're going Secondly But that's
the goal that's what we try to do so that's the so the bulk of the work was headed south Asia though and
then cost was the oldest and then some of them more recently have had problems
because of the corporate
value tremendously so what people pay to if you're out for a net worth three hundred thousand dollars and is
precious to you that the self the people on the side of it and some people some situations.
A couple of peculiar building and try to make a profit on them that they can go back and all the
stuff that's the third thing we do is reps and community
coalitions. Going back to that separate time and
over all kinds of issues rezoning.
Environmental stuff we work with coalitions will be given that that's another major part of
that but the early Fair Housing is one of the major issues that affected the series continues to.
And where the first case of the
report was a lease break for how the waves break for Housing
Committee challenged the cities the city's behavior in this
respect shocking behavior in this
area racist strict racial quotas in public housing
favoring basic Jewish community and
just innocently. So in the Jewish dream. He ran on the south side white
flight mention two recently the project to build public health right over here.
And and near by the way John Salinas houses and. Independents houses together
about his hundred apartments.
I mean we found out that there was one hundred fifty four when it opened up.
We found that one hundred seventy six over here the situation. That they had been read stuff seventy five percent
white and maintain strictly strictly strictly from the fact that white is really Jewish.
Through a critic Amos a refuge for the Jews that will be out the neighborhood.
I suppose other areas where they moved to Los Angeles or the Isle of Long Island
here many of them stayed here because they are grateful. And it was segregated.
In one thousand nine hundred six so
we. Let you know community based the Puerto Rican community which is
which is changed over the years and became organ Minnick you know. Have you looked at
Mexicans and other. But the time was all Puerto
Rican they came really after World War two It was some always there as it was a Hispanic
community but really the his security community really came in large numbers for different reasons if
the world were to have his security stating that the remnants of the Jewish community
in
Europe. Some of the survivors came and then the lead put we can communicate
and post or drop saying they're working to get jobs here and
along the waterfront a lot of destructions. And they came in really at the road and
they kind of threw together. You have to report to the security community
has dramatic patterns
of childbirth because of religious rules and
otherwise they have the maximum number of children so every family has twelve or thirteen kids
or no kids of that have children at the
maximum it has a mega
growth that way he lets you know he's grown by immigration.
So put a great group of truth in that then replaced
by major in front of the Minicons And then as if at the next.
So but they have grown together to give them the put the Latino community is larger than it is
anything but. He said he votes as a block. I mean part of the issue with this
agree that eighty percent of the population is
loving teens because of the child so that their voting bloc is
tremendous missing small the bull population is if we smaller than the less you know population that
however has security both supply. It's led by the by the religious
leaders and the secular uses that dictate how the vote is going to block votes. I'll
give you five thousand votes or four thousand votes or give your opponent both of
them and I'm not a Democrat or Republican. I'm not conservative or liberal I can support a
gay black woman over a Jewish guy any
time. But here's what you
do and nobody wants to lose a thousand or ten thousand
votes in the
city not in the state and as a result not federal.
Jimmy Carter if President were taken
forward to his sixteen I did that four to four pm that
if they hold off to the go shares with children then they finally go to
court and let's check in to political pressure so
racial
quotas study in sixty four but New York City.
The government not some private landlord strict and the way this has always
been over ninety percent on white usually about fifty five percent black and forty percent
Latino So yes we brought litigation in federal court in seventy six.
We discovered in the new how this is because of the housing going up fifteen hundred years against Of the five percent
revenue racial quotas and seventy six and there was one project five hundred
apartments New York City public
health sixty percent Hispanic. So you percent
Latino ten percent African-American every fourth exactly the same
for a B.C. you like
acidic lets you know.
Despite this thing. It was maintained that
way so that was the forgot the last of the stop them for the development of the court
order barring it and that was eight hundred seventy six in the seventh one thousand nine hundred
one to the world changes to go back to a value to the peer that new
housing is going
up on the waterfront.
Eleven city had newer been to New renewal development along the
waterfront eleven sites every single one was given notice that it developed for his sick only purpose
of housing for them
only with market rate housing so that lets you know can afford in
the Shivas or dormitories housing
for his
own and things like
that to grow if a challenge that we also reviewed the price situation the product
court ordered and lo and behold despite a federal court
order the city maintained
that members of all the fifty three thousand between one thousand nine hundred sixty one thousand and one thousand one
thousand and ninety one
means they violated a federal order to maintain strict racial
and discriminatory as over the years after that too and we were going to Puerto Rican Legal Defense Fund.
A deliberate intent case through two thousand
and five until the Lisa See's part of it was that these projects as
of two thousand left the project remain all the public health things here in Maine every single large
apartment occupied by whites in his system
and collectively only slightly less than five percent their parts
are occupied by whites. There's been some change but when it's been over ninety
percent triple protect
them so bizarre and shocking. What happens
is a sick feeling will
then the old is legal that but then when it was over
that remained
there really
they they have their children
stay at least. Like your thing moving and the children generations
it is
some hocus pocus bills
and so that contains minutes we have to do a lot of
litigation about that and there are other things like the
great waterfront in two thousand and five when they go should represent to the coalition that negotiate
a settlement of the city no no no no litigation but the contagion of the groups
and demonstrations and the Goetia in the city to
maximize another for the healthy living. We now involved in mega
litigation involving the Broadway Triangle area which is a large urban area at the intersection of that's
the Williamsburg. Because once again the Bloomberg
administration. Gave over sixty percent of the city and
territory to a civic coalition with some people up it was very politically
very powerful political figures. Had they had to keep happy Democratic
Party
and and I don't like the way that was the only company that has secured.
Low rise that will you feel it is a
savage
and just a cover up was a living. The result. Only
the bullies break sites we use birth for means the five
percent black despite a lot of blacks living in public health.
A lot of Public Health says I see no African-Americans living up to that I thought a public
outing Waynesburg three point let the five percent
black that start right across the
border over the Broadway tribal or renewal
area is was over seventy five percent really close to ninety percent that America was
separated recently seventy five
percent. The only reason on the Waynesburg side.
That's a good excuse for them for the real reason was that your fifty percent preference for affordable housing
built in these areas to residents of the local
area in this case board
was saving these so that you know you've been including me or three also look at
that site. It was a clue that the. The problem that we
got so all this craziness going on in the nation the.
One time we actually came together with his security. Because the city had plans.
To kind of deal with the when they close
the garbage sites to the dump and that with a double to go up to instead
of this that night when they if they built a Verizon bridge
that they would pay for like look at a landfill in Staten Island or all the garbage near things with them.
So they had to find out what do we do with the government now. So the plan was to have a
single in garbage incinerator in each
barrel and they've missed at least part of course in progress that the Brooklyn It's
an array of the fifty seven story Center eight are right at the Navy
Yard right next to public housing. You know so so they sit here
and let you know he can get
it and we watched over the purpose of that Weaver bridge to City Hall and all kinds of stuff but it
was great thinking together and saying that to
do stuff like that so
that those companies and I did a lot of press stuff also had pension
work with give took its I was they were like was the borders of the way because we don't just do
the litigation. We have well we're very close
to what you said injuries.
Yes
Yes well unfortunately like I said we're trying to be very active case minute for the what
you
can tease to be issues like that but
rezoning displacement pressures created by that we
see the slumlords now it's gentrification and use displaced pressures.
So the resulting allowing for the creation
of mark a great helping. If you have a significant twenty thirty
percent of what will
help it a definition of what was not to affordable to our communities but
be the construction of. Market rate
housing. Does not meet that demand increase
it becomes a magnet and huge displacement pressure. So it's a war. So it's just like with
the flood was an elf a war against limits. If they can get five thousand dollars for a two
bedroom I think it twenty five
dollars for a two bedroom apartment and people paying a legal rights they left
with a simple and struggling to pay seven hundred forty three dollars bill kill to get
it and that's what's happening.
And so we've had
and I love his criminality. I'll show you a
new op ed piece we did for the you Daily News recently last month.
That said that the little bit of the myth about the criminal
behavior that is being treated as housing cases that actually it's totally criminal behavior you
know plenty of people burning buildings down all that kind of stuff.
So it's a worry when we continue to do that I'm as a metaphorical reps of the organ working
with the organizers continuing to the tenants and then to
the also the co-ops remain a major issue often sustain them to
live off the edges of a lot of the same stuff.
What can you think that it's.
Well I think like I said my my my
my my childhood having lost my community and that want to
see
have the successes the it's
very
empowering like realize that I've been blessed because I've had situations where really it's
that
individual low income people have no power. So when people who are low
income coming together and having power and winning the battles and
in the affirmative battles and not just use that line the courts to
dominate the power people to to force labor and the rest of the world
to realize that they have to deal with them.
Fortunately it continues with the new
mare. We are unfortunately talking to.
But a lot of what's happened. Continues to be the same stuff at the street level not
an overt not functionality you control at the street level a lot of people who work in the city
are carry overs for holding their traditions and old
visions the big vision was benign neglect.
Let's put that don't help poor people and move out of the neighborhoods and let's get rich people in and pay our
taxes if this is a condominium vibrant your city built the
parks enough of the people that get to the people vote.
And that's what's next. He's to be very much a case of
spite claims otherwise. And also you've been a lot
of attention to the Blodgett reaching out to the ones
that you're ready to secure community and
again try to work within trying to get that support in order to do it in the New York Times about that.
But the whole circumcision thing but they say it was a much larger issue in terms of
him try to
accommodate him and make friends with his fortune I believe
is part of what's going on here as well we also are
involved with the city the Bloomberg administration.
Unfortunately continues today the city is abandoned take you said
to me
but I'm going
to live a life in the not renewing leases and allow them to be forced out
which is the
infrastructure where you know.
And part of it is was the old benign neglect situation but now
the budget is strange and I don't know because it's shocking
the consistent behavior but to the pocket about
the people to look
into
for people who
have. Raise
the
bar that has
seven Great thank you nurturing community centers
it's part of the community.
Staines provides all that they both want people to work.
And
able to do you think you have a loving environment there truly neighborhood based environment.
Also I believe somebody has to be privy to
the city leadership who are connected to the park.
So I don't feel like I can think it was a wise ministration has not
moved to protect this place we're fighting that
when we always win but the question is how much
of
anything else you want
to not really I
mean also the block where I live. I've lived there for forty four was
over forty for forty two three years. That's become I know a new village and brain knows each other
and despite the pressures elsewhere. Most of the buildings on my
block and some of the surrounding area
are owned by
non-profits or teach the F.C.S.
and a lot of people who remain are the children of the average And so it's again it's
like sort of like the village kind of environment and supportive and nurturing friendly.
But a very good part of my life as
well thank you so much for taking time out of your day because
I got off my
pleasure.